welcome to this video is a bit late to
start but I had some wrong setup in my
head in my recording software they
needed to fix that first okay the girl
played the guy who played h4 huh okay
yeah all this stuff is possible in the
Trump of ski but is this really good hmm
really wonder what about c5 is sg6 idea
that might be tricky with playing in the
center cannot be bad or him okay so
knight c6 or maybe let's let's clarify
this and now go g6 this g6 idea always
seems irritating okay okay yeah I mean
if it takes I will have two bishops
against two nights they don't really
know why it is on b5 this piece I cannot
really believe that he is going to
Castle long in this position maybe is
but Queen a 5 has also moved Queen B 6
yeah at least I've caught up on the
clock that's good
hmm yeah I don't know what you should do
and stuff like that Queen B 6 now
attacking the the bishop and the pawn on
d4 trying to be because they're the kind
of person who plays h4 in the trumpets
and also the kind of person will
probably play every every nonsense it
could position positional time let's see
on a five and Bishop a six or something
like that a5 a4 and yeah that's probably
not a bad idea not sure people you
cannot really allow that a fall from
some from black soil backside bishop a6
would actually prevent Hardcastle's and
long castling oh yeah not easy for him
to do that now maybe I put it here
there's also the idea maybe to play
Queen before at some point and Bishop c4
is also
he goes Queen f3 for the main threat
here are almost made thread I will just
take the take the night and play Bishop
c4 I'm not sure about what white should
do now I'm going to take that I don't
really I cannot really cancel short
probably because of Queen edge threesome
going to take care and now we are there
are many good ideas going before small
let's do that and not think about it too
long one of the good moves Bishop c4 was
also good you cannot go see 392 gives
away b2 and e5 King the one thing that
looks very unattractive Quincy three
days queen e 4 check as well yeah what
now the sisters is certainly not great
but how to exploit it Bishop c4 simply
yeah maybe
yeah and we had pawn structure here with
a 5 and g5 but it also limits my pieces
so some end games might actually be
tricky intending to take and play Queen
deform I can do Bishop e2 check and win
the rook it's no big reason not to I
guess I win the exchange to be to be
entirely correct yeah I guess castles
right or or taking there is no real
point in taking that's castle takes rook
takes immediately takes f 2 he really
has misplaced pieces here with the Nitro
and stuff right this should be really
really good for black ok taking can also
take g5 it's no real reason not to or
this check or you could be for look
before it's looking a nice actually
intending to activate the rookie I like
rookie for into the check on h1 I had
that's quite good if he move to the
night I can take be too that seems
pretty clear
and rookie for is the threat intending
queen h 1y
I'm okay so what what are we going to do
here just this rookie for business and
then then the Queen check that looks
really strong and taking 1 B 2 looks
also strong but this is pretty good
Queen age 3 there is Queen f2 and in
other cases i can take here right you
can give the check on f7 rook takes
Queen see a check yeah those threats
only one a little bit too much white
resign yeah it was not a really good
position out of the opening I'm unsure
about the theory here I mean h4 is
somewhat dicey move that's not really
great i believe but i'm not really sure
what the right way to play is i think
like mostly try stuff like c5 but i just
wanted to stay solid here with h5 why
not you ain't here now I took the bishop
you know this just makes some sense I
guess getting the two bishops and
slightly yeah deforming ass bone
structure but this part is always tricky
as the moves like that can be a problem
I don't think it really is one at the
moment but it sort of forces me to take
with the pawn and this is kind of kind
of shaky I'm a piece taking on g6 and ik
let's say stuff like that it could be
could be tricky but he went here and
after the trade I got in g6 ja ja iya
blacks already been fine I guess
yeah and this some stuff hanging so
probably had to do that and now I mean
after 85 i think i just have the
initiative like threatens a for already
went here and now yeah Bishop f5 is
probably good but this is also shouldn't
be bad went here and after that the
capture Jack I think King be one Bishop
c4 yes here's the point where he I
expected him to play Quincy three but
she didn't do that this is quite a good
idea because if I capture hear this oops
there is this okay this idea so maybe I
have to take and this could be a pretty
decent transformation form for what yeah
this is probably what he should do but
after that I think it here this will
cause blundered material but it was a
very tricky anyway yeah okay thanks for
watching